Hello everyone. This is Chin with Next
Level Commander. Who would have thought
just two days after my very thorough and
comprehensive video on Ugu, I have to
make another to address the many little
mistakes I made in the first video.
Doing my best CD project writing
impression over here. But also, I may or
may not have gotten the rules wrong with
my epic end game plan. Now, the endgame
still works and it's still epic, but
it's just a little bit different. But
none of this is actually why I decided
to make another video. The reason is
because that first video had the most
amazing comment section I've ever had
the pleasure of reading and responding
to and the number of sick tech that you
guys brought up. I lost track of how
many times I thought to myself, "Ah
crap, how did I not think of that?"
Yeah, there are definitely some sweet
cards that I missed and I will address
all of those here. Also, there are a lot
of common questions, so those will be
answered. But first, let's address the
elephant in the room. The one that
people really care about. Why is the
card called Ugu and not Ugub? or why is
the mana cost not blue green blue blue
blue blue blue blue blue blue blue blue
blue blue blue blue blue blue valid
criticism but unfortunately as
influential as I am there's not much I
can do about this one however I urge you
to write an angry negative review for
Wizards of the Coast strike them where
it hurts and they will remember for next
time and now let's move on from Wizards
of the Coast's incompetence to mine
which is pretty negligible by comparison
I only messed up the entire rules thing
for the endame luckily I have these
helpful commenters to correct me and now
I know that when a clone copies Ugu and
it dies the tokens I make will copy Ugus
and I cannot choose new targets. So, our
epic end game requires another step and
that step is conspiracy effects.
Actually, that was the original game
plan. My first draft of the video had
this, but then after playing a few games
with the deck, I started second
guessing. I thought maybe the clones can
just make clone tokens on deck. I
checked with a few friends and a judge
and changed the video last minute. But
now, I know with certainty that
conspiracies are needed. I've always
wanted to build decks with conspiracy,
but it's very difficult because they
warp your deck building and everything
falls apart when you don't have one. But
in this deck, the payoff is massive
compared to the relatively low
opportunity cost. So, how does it work?
Well, let's say I have a conspiracy.
Actually, I ended up cutting conspiracy.
So, let's use Arcan adaptation. So, with
that and a few ugles on the field, now I
can play any of my clones, but not copy
anything. So, the clone will die as a
zero zero ooze. And when it does, each
ugu on the field will create two copies
of the clone, which then I can use to
copy anything. Be it Ellish Norins,
Hawkeye Tyrants, or even just more Ugus.
But yeah, that's the plan. So, I started
with five conspiracy effects, but I've
since dropped it down to three because
we have enough draw power. And also, we
don't want this in the early game. I do
think three is enough. And I also
decided to swap one of them for march of
the world boots after seeing
quintentions comment because not only
does it enable our shenanigans, it also
turns the ug six sixes which then we can
just use to beat people down. The other
two I chose are Arcane Adaptation and
Masswood Nexus just because they're the
cheapest ones in terms of mana cost. So
yeah, that's our end game. It doesn't
have to work every time cuz a lot of the
games you can just win with Ugu
Beatdown. Just by looping clone three
times, you already have a lethal number
of two twos. Four times and you're
killing the entire table. Okay, so
that's settled. Just to address another
mistake I made in the first video with
World of Invention. It does not have
convoke. It has improvise which does not
work with this deck. I'm replacing it
with court of calling. It has fewer
targets, but convoke is so good here
because your ugu tokens are ug. So most
of the convoke spells are free. I
decided to add another one in
transcendent message, but if you want to
go even deeper, there's all kinds of
utility you can find with convoke. A
really interesting line I found involves
hoarding brood lord. Then a decent
board, you can cast it pretty much for
free. You search for arcane adaptation,
drop that with convoke, and now you sack
the brood lord, which is now in ooze,
and now every ugu on the field will
create for you two tokens of the brood
lord, which you can then use to tutor
for more clones for anything really.
Yeah, you go infinite from there. That's
actually such a sweet line, but why am I
not doing it? Well, this is where we
address a lot of the questions. Why
aren't you playing this? Why aren't you
playing that? And a lot of them are like
amazing suggestions, wonderful cards,
starting with, for example, Crater Hoof.
Yeah, why am I not playing Crater Hoof?
Well, the reason is because Ugu actually
ticks so many boxes in terms of synergy
and there's so many directions you can
take. A lot of the best windcons in
these colors Ugu can use, whether it's
combo or tokens. Food chain, for
example, that goes off very easily with
Ugu. But the reason I'm not jamming all
of them into the deck is because we want
to keep the deck consistent. Like we
want to keep the core strong. When you
have the core with clones and undying
effects, you can create Ugus
consistently. You can win with whatever
you want, but you don't want to dilute
that core. you can probably still win
the game if you draw a bunch of clones
and undying effects but none of the
fancy wind conditions. On the flip side,
if you draw a bunch of these mass pump
effects or combo pieces, but not enough
of our engine, your game is not going to
go well. So, we keep it low to the
ground. And for wind condition, I'm only
going with these conspiracy effects
because this is a play pattern that is
unique to this deck. And it sounds like
such a blast, doesn't it? Yeah, I would
look forward to doing this every time I
pick up Ugu, but I can't say the same
about Critter Hoof. With that said, I'm
going to go over some of the directions
we can take and you can pick and choose
whichever one speaks to you. Starting
with tokens and sacrifice. I'm sure
you're familiar with this, but any of
the blood artist effects can win games,
but you will need to go a bit heavier on
sack outlets. Then you get to abuse
cards like grave pack, parallel lives,
all that good stuff, but Ian Verdine
brought up the best one, Mirwood bats.
This and a few clones, and the game is
over, so that works. On the other hand,
we can also focus more on tribal
synergies. We already have cards like
that. For example, harmonized crescendo
and three Tree City, but the one I
missed is Skimar Shadow Mage as
mentioned by Jane Kosovisk. I'm sure
there are lots of other tribal cards
that I can also use. Let me know in the
comments if after all this I'm still
missing some heavy hitters. And after
this we have devotion because once again
every token has a mana cost. Yeah, we're
definitely playing Nthos, but we can
also play a lot of these if you want to.
Imagine winning with Thasa's Oracle in
the fairway. That would be such a flex.
Also, of course, we have Grey Merchant.
Even aspect of the Hydra, you can
probably commander damage someone with
that. And we are getting spicier and
spicier. Now, now I'm I'm not sure if I
should be doing this. We are treading
into another dangerous territory in
terms of rules, and that is mutate. Now,
if you mutate onto Ugu and place the
mutate card on the bottom, Ugu will
remain in ooze, but also gain the card's
ability, which can then be copied. This
is relevant for cards like Sea Dasher
Octopus and Parcel Beast. But yeah,
these are just a few examples of things
we can do. There are tons more awaiting
your exploration. But before that, I
also want to address some of the sweet
tech that are being suggested. The first
one is Prime Speaker Vanifar. Yes, with
this I won't be able to do my clickbay
title, but it actually makes so much
sense here. I play her. I sacrifice her
into however many copies of herself. And
once I untap, I get to pod all the Ugus.
Conveniently, all the Ugus, even the
token copies, are three mana value, and
most of our clones are four. If you do
include this, I would recommend also
including something like the Superior
Spider-Man and a body double for more
looping shenanigans. Another one is Soul
Stone Sanctuary. Now, this one I just
forgot about cuz Mutavolt has amazing
synergy with the deck. You can turn it
on, sacrifice it, or even just do it in
response to a board wipe, and you get a
bunch of Mutiva tokens for future use. I
also looked at Faceless Haven, but
unfortunately the snow mana is a bit
rough. But then Soulstone Sanctuary,
even with a four mana activation cost,
is well worth the upside. So definitely
put that in. And similarly, Corrupted
Zendicon. Yeah, how deep is that? Put
that onto any land, sacrifice it, and
boom, you are set for mana for the rest
of the game. Or if you don't have a sack
outlet, put it onto a fetch land. I
added a few more fetch lands for this.
Although, do keep in mind you actually
have to fetch the tokens as well. So
you're limited by your life total and
also how many lands you have in the
deck. But it's it's still pretty good.
Next up, Mirror of the Four Beers. It's
a card that I just completely forgot
about. I don't usually use it anywhere,
but here it makes a lot of sense cuz
it's like a clone that you can drop
early and you can reuse it. Just keep
targeting Ugu and it will have the same
effect as a clone except you can keep it
on the board as a sack outlet. And
finally, I don't know how I missed this.
It's one of my favorite cards in all of
Magic. Mirror form. Yeah, this can be
anything. Wind condition, like in
response to a board wipe, turn all your
Ugus into lands or if there's something
nice to copy on the field, like say a
koku show. This is basically like an
overrun effect, right? You can turn your
oozes into something huge and you can do
some clone shenanigans. So, in the late
game, it's like the effects of March of
the World ooze and a clone on one card.
Yeah, that's pretty sweet. And that
wraps up part two of Ugu, the electric
boou. Um, Bugulu.
Anyways, do check out the deck list. I
made a budget version. I also included
the regular version at full power. I
will constantly update them and I'm 100%
sure that even now I there are a lot of
interactions and a lot of sick tech that
I still don't know about. But anyways,
this is Jin with Next Level Commander. I
am building a lot more decks from this
set. Also, Hobbit. So if you enjoy this
kind of content, like and subscribe and
I will see you in the next